[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is Krapopolis.
I swear it's not as bad as the
name sounds or that looked.
I bet he deserved it.
In a land of gods
and goddesses--
Athena, goddess of-- what's
the list up to now-- war,
over-the-top outfits,
and daddy issues?
One ruler--
I can't believe
the king's a virgin.
Hey, I'm only a
below the waist virgin.
Is about to change
the world forever.
It's called
civilization, mother.
Yeah, catchy name.
That'll stick.
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[SCREAMING]
My bad.
You've got a great
story now though.
Prepare for adventure--
We haven't seen the last
of each other, King Tyrannus.
[YELPING]
He says ya to himself?
Romance--
I know a recipe for
an orgy when I hear one.
You hear recipes
for orgies every day.
It's a pretty simple recipe.
And some good old-fashioned
family dysfunction.
I asked her out.
What!
Son, details.
There are none.
Make them up.
That's childish.
I'm childish.
Daddy needy deety.
We're going to
build an empire.
Attack!
What's an empire?
I don't know yet, but
it's going to be huge.
(SINGING) I'm so on fire.
Guess what today is.
Everyone guesses
what every day is.
We have no calendar.
The day you speak quietly?
You're all wrong!
(SINGING) I'm so on fire.
I call them pants.
It's as if each
leg has its own toga.
Well, done.
To pants!
[CHEERING]
This civilization
thing, it is the mortals
doing the best they can.
There's a guy collecting
pig feces over your shoulder.
They call it agriculture.
We'll finesse it later.
"Krapopolis," special
premiere September 24th on FOX.
Random animal exit.
How is she hot
even as an ostrich?